- And you may not know
it, but some of the people
that are giving you the most trouble
may be helping you more than anybody.
You have no idea how frighteningly average
and normal I am, if you
have a habit of just talking
about your problems all the time,
it's time to make a new habit.
Bunch of people old
before their times because
they look like, they're 40
and look like they're 90
because they've worried
themselves to death.
- She's a charismatic
Christian speaker, author,
and pastor, she speaks
humorously with her audience,
sharing her personal
stories and often taking
small jabs at stereotypical
church behavior.
Time magazine also named her
one of the 25 most influential
evangelicals in America,
she's Joyce Meyer,
and here's my take on her
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number four is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
ones you guys like the best.
Also, as Joyce is talking,
if she says something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
and also when you write it
down, it helps lock it in
for yourself, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- I tell a story about
a poor pitiful donkey
that got thrown down into a
well, he fell into a well,
and the farmer heard this
donkey crying in the well
and he was trying to
debate on whether or not
to try to get him out or
not, the well was deep
and it was going to be a lot of hard work
and the donkey was old anyway
and so maybe we'll just
bury him and let it go, so he went and got
a bunch of friends and
said, let's just bury him,
help me shovel some dirt
in there, so he'll shut up
that crying, he's an old
donkey and not worth too much
anyway, you know, there
may be a lot of people
that just think you're just an old donkey
and not worth too much anyway,
maybe feel like you're in a pit right now
and somebody's shoveling dirt on you.
But what are you going to do about it?
Well, the donkey's down
there and he's crying out
pitifully. (brays)
And here comes a shovelful
of dirt and another shovelful
and a shovelful of dirt, and
it would hit him on the back,
and he'd go ...
(audience laughs)
Get on top of it, here
comes some more dirt
and some more dirt and some more dirt.
He'd shake it off his back,
he'd wiggle just a little.
He couldn't get out of the
pit, but he could wiggle
and he'd get up on top of that dirt
and he was getting closer
and closer to the top
and pretty soon he just
walked right out of that pit.
(audience cheers)
All those people shoveling
dirt on him helped him
get out of the pit.
Are you out there tonight?
All those people shoveling dirt on him
actually helped him,
and you may not know it
but some of the people that are giving you
the most trouble may be helping you more
than anybody, are you living
an unsustainable life?
Do you find yourself saying,
I can't do this much longer?
I just can't keep this up forever.
This is just too much for me,
or are other people telling
you you can't keep going
on like this forever?
How many of you got some people
in your life that love you
telling you you can't keep
this up, you can't keep
doing this, you're going
to have to slow down,
you're going to have
to lay something down,
you're going to have to give something up?
Well Moses had the same
thing, he was overloaded
but to be honest I don't
know that he really knew it
and you know, I'm such a
hard worker that sometimes
I can not even realize
that I'm doing too much,
sometimes I don't even know
when I'm being excessive
and somebody has to come
along and say, wait a minute,
you're not going to do
that, you just got back
from a conference, you're going to rest,
so sometimes it pays to
listen to other people.
Exodus 18:14.
"When Moses' father in
law saw what he was doing
"for the people, he said,
what is this that you do
"for the people, why do you sit alone
"and the people stand around
you from morning till evening?
Now listen, Mom, why do
you wait on your children
hand and foot while they
sit around and watch you
and do nothing but play on
their iPads from morning
till evening?
(audience cheers)
Well ... (laughs)
Let me tell you something,
that kid of yours
can put cereal in a bowl.
(audience cheers)
They might make a little mess,
but it won't be the end of the world.
If you're enjoying yourself
sitting in your recliner
and you're relaxing, let
'em get their own snack.
Oh, boy, come on, I don't
want to work this hard
on Friday night, why do you
sit alone while everybody
stands around you, now you
don't all have that problem
but I have a daughter that does that.
You can just get into
habits and the way you start
with people is what they're
going to expect later on,
so then if you've already
got a bunch of bad habits
in your house, then it's
going to really kind of shock
everybody when you kind
of bring down the gauntlet
and say I'm not going to
live like this anymore,
and they're going to
think you're being mean
and think you're being
bad and so there'll be
a little time of adjustment
and it doesn't mean you don't do anything
for anybody but don't let
people take advantage of you,
have some boundaries and some borders.
Some of you need a laugh right now,
so I'm going to stop right in
the middle of this preaching
and tell you a joke.
(audience laughs)
Well, honey, I've never been
in a church like this, well,
two old people were laying
in bed side by side.
I'm talking really old,
like, wrinkled up old.
And she said, honey, why don't you ever
hold my hand like you used to at night?
So his little old wrinkled
hand came across the bed
and he took her little old wrinkled hand,
she said, honey, why
don't you ever hold me
in your arms like you used to at night?
So he sighed and it
took him a little while
but he got over to her side of the bed,
got her in his arms and
she rested a little bit
and then she said,
honey, why don't you ever
nibble on my ear like you
used to at night? (laughs)
And all of a sudden he
jumped up and started
across the floor, and she said,
well, where are you going,
and he said, well, I got to get my teeth.
(audience laughs)
Now see, you're thinking,
well, what does that have to do
with anything, nothing, it has
nothing to do with anything
and that's exactly what you
need to get through your head
that everything doesn't
have to have some big
super duper purpose.
(audience cheers)
It's okay to just stop right
in the middle of some work
and just have a little bit of fun,
matter of fact, you
could laugh at yourself
and lighten up your life a whole lot.
Look at me and let me tell you something,
you can believe what you
want to believe. (laughs)
You're going to believe
something, it might as well
be something that is going to help you.
It's just as simple, actually,
it's easier to believe
you can than to believe you can't.
It's easier to believe
you are than to believe
you aren't, now, you know,
based on what you guys
tell me, you love me,
you like me, you know,
you tell me, I think you're
this, I think you're that,
blah blah blah, you've changed my life,
you have no idea how frighteningly
average and normal I am.
(audience laughs)
I mean, it's like sometimes
I'm walking around
and somebody'll run up
to me and say (screams)
You're Joyce Meyer, and I'm,
like, oh, yeah, oh yeah,
I'm Joyce Meyer. (laughs)
(audience cheers and claps)
But see, actually the
truth is I'm just like you
and you're just like me,
we're all just a big mess.
(audience laughs)
With Jesus living on the
inside, saying you got
what it takes, if there is any difference
in me and you and there
doesn't have to be,
but if there is any, it's
only because I've decided
to believe it and you haven't
quite decided that yet.
You can get over a broken
past if you decide to believe
that there's nothing in
your past that can keep you
from having a great future.
First Peter 5:8 says be well balanced,
are you living a balanced life?
How many of you don't get enough sleep,
no matter where I go, it's the same thing,
80% of the people don't get enough sleep,
well, what's going to
fix it, start sleeping.
(audience laughs)
(laughs) That's simple, get more sleep.
Well, I can't sleep, I
have trouble sleeping,
well, don't spend all day worrying,
then maybe you'll be able
to go to sleep at night.
How many of you don't drink enough water?
Well, we can fix that too, drink water.
(audience laughs)
This is not rocket science, I
mean, I'm trying to tell you
tonight that you can fix your life faster
than you think you can fix your life.
Fear is something that's not ever
going to completely disappear
from our lives, the
feeling of fear is not ever
going to completely disappear,
and just because you feel fear
that doesn't mean that
you have to be afraid,
and I don't know about you,
but that was a great revelation
to me many years ago
because I kept wanting
to not feel afraid and God
wanted me to feel the fear
and be courageous anyway,
courage means to go ahead
and take the action that
you believe you should take
or that you know that
God wants you to take
while you feel fear.
We let our feelings
dictate to us way too much,
and so the only acceptable
attitude that a Christian can
have is simply I will not fear.
So let's all say that, I will not fear.
Now, once again, that doesn't mean
that you'll never feel
fear, matter of fact,
I can pretty much
promise you that you will
but it does mean that
you can feel the fear,
do whatever you believe
that you're supposed to do
while you feel afraid, you
can learn to do it afraid
if that's the only way that you can do it.
Don't let the feelings
of fear keep you trapped
any longer, now first
of all, let me say this,
a positive attitude attracts people,
a negative attitude
usually doesn't win you
very many friends, now,
I don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings, but I
just want to throw this out
for you to think about,
everybody does not want
to just hear your problems all the time.
(audience laughs)
Now it's great to have a good friend
that you can share with
but you don't have to
share and share and share
and share and share.
And share and share, and then
when you wear that one out,
go find another one and
share and share and share.
(audience laughs)
So if you have a habit of just
talking about your problems
all the time, it's time
to make a new habit,
and that is to find
something good to talk about
and I'll just throw this
out for good measure, too.
Your friends don't want to just hear you
talk about yourself all the time.
And I remember God telling me
in the very, very beginning
of our ministry, if you
can not complain about
where you go to meetings,
the day will come
when you'll be able to
go anywhere you want to
and hold a meeting, well,
that's pretty much true today
but I had to go through
a lot of rough places
and difficult places, and
I think a lot of people,
and I want you to listen
to me, a lot of people
never get to where they want
to be because they'll never
stop complaining about where they're at,
I'ma say it again, a lot
of people will never get
to where they want to be
because they will never stop
complaining about where
they're at, the word complain
means to remain or to stay overnight,
so if you want to stay
right where you're at,
just keep complaining about
it, and I can pretty much
guarantee you that you'll still be there
this time next year.
I mean, can we believe
tonight that Jesus didn't die
so we could be wimpy and
whiny and barely going,
I'm just so tired of
this, I just don't know
if I can make it or not, Jesus (whines)
(audience laughs)
Come on.
Bunch of people old before
their times because they look,
you know, they're 40
and look like they're 90
because they worried themselves to death.
(audience claps)
I mean, come on, you stay
full of the Holy Ghost
and you're going to look
younger when you're 80
than you did when you were 40.
(audience cheers)
Let's look at Acts
chapter one verse eight.
(laughs) Look at this, "But
you shall receive power."
I knew that God had power,
but I went to church
for years and nobody told
me I could have any power.
So just in case nobody's ever told you,
I want to tell you in
this room and all of you
watching by television
all around the world
in these 63 languages this
program is translated into,
whether you're in China or
Russia or India or Africa,
you can have power.
(audience cheers)
God wants you to have power
to live your everyday life,
where even when we are
loaded down with troubles,
we can throw our shoulders
back and lift our head up
and say I can do whatever
I need to do through Christ
who strengthens me.
I am not without an answer,
I am not without a way,
because God is living in
me in close fellowship
and he will show me what to do.
If we don't understand the power of God,
no wonder, being a Christian is so boring,
there's nothing you can do.
Let me just tell you
that I was so selfish,
oh my gosh, I was so selfish,
I was always on my mind.
(audience laughs)
You know, if Dave was
going to go play golf,
the first thing I'd think
is, well, what about me?
And if Dave was going to
watch a football game,
well, what about me?
The kids'd go outside with
Dave to play and I had work
to do inside, you know, mind
you, I could've not worked
and went out and enjoyed myself, but no,
I wanted to work so I could
feel sorry for myself.
(audience laughs)
And everything was, well,
what about me, what about me,
when's somebody going
to do something for me
and I started early in the
morning, before I was even
fully awake thinking about myself.
(audience laughs)
Any of you like that?
And so many many many years
ago I was laying in bed
one morning, and I wasn't
even fully awake yet
and I was thinking about
how I could get Dave to
not do what he wanted to do that day
and do what I wanted and,
you know, how I could maybe
get the kids to do the
housework so I could just
kind of chill and, you know, have fun,
and it was like I was just
thinking about myself,
just laying there in bed,
and you know, that's a
dangerous way to start your day
because however you get
started, that's usually
the way things go the rest of the day,
and you're much better off to lay in bed
and purposely think, God, what can I do
for somebody else today, how
can I be a greater blessing
to my family, God, how can
I be a better wife today?
The last time I asked God that,
he told me to cook Dave some breakfast,
I haven't asked that in a while.
(audience laughs)
'Cause I'm not into too much cooking
and poor guy about fainted when I said
I'm going to cook your breakfast, so.
You got to be ready when you
ask God that kind of stuff
but it's been life changing for me
the principles that I'm
sharing with you tonight
really has been one of the
key elements in my life
that have gotten me from
where I was to where I am,
so I'm laying there thinking about myself
and I kind of had,
like, this little vision
and the Holy Ghost began
to deal with me in my heart
and he said, you know, the
enemy comes and starts putting
thoughts in your head
real early in the morning
and it's like he's getting
you wound up for the day,
he said, you remind me
of this little robot,
the devil comes and he's,
like, what about me,
what about me, what about
me and what about me?
And then you put your feet on the floor
and this is the way you look
to me the rest of the day.
(robotic voice) What
about me, what about me,
what about me, what about me, beep beep,
what about me, what
about me, what about me.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Natasha O'Meara asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'll also love to know what did Joyce say
that had the biggest impact on you,
which rule did you love the most and why,
leave it in the comments,
I'm going to join
in the discussion, finally,
want to give a quick shoutout
to MeGaPuRe, thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and making that awesome
Youtube video on your channel,
I really really really
appreciate the support and
hope you're enjoying the book.
(gentle music)
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
your one word is, much love,
I'll see you soon.
- You know, we all have really
the same amount of time,
each of us gets 24 hours every day,
we don't get any more,
we don't get any less.
Well, why is it that some
people can do so much
with their time and
other people don't seem
to ever accomplish what
they set out to accomplish
with their time, we hear
this comment all the time,
or we hear ourselves
saying it, I know I say it,
where did all the time go, I can't believe
this day has gone, I can't
believe it's already spring,
I can't believe it's
Christmas, and we hear that
all the time, well, where
does all the time go?
To be honest, I think we
should know where our time goes
and one of the things
that I've formed the habit
of doing, I don't do it every
single day, but this really
helps me, is people who live
busy lives, fast-paced lives,
sometimes a whole day can go by in a blur
and you know you were busy
but you're not really sure
what you did, you did it all so fast
that you can't even hardly
remember what you did,
and one of the things that I enjoy doing
is just laying in bed for
a few minutes at night
before I drift off to
sleep and actually starting
with my morning in my
thoughts and thinking about
everything that I did that day, I got up,
made my coffee, went up to my office,
had some time with God,
looked over my calendar,
you know, whatever it was
that I did, I like to go
through those things because
then it actually helps me
remember what I'm doing with my life.
I don't want my life to go by in a blur
and I don't think you do either, I believe
that every day that God gives us is a gift
and I think we should open
that gift fully and completely,
enjoy every single moment of it.
Some people don't enjoy
their lives because they feel
like they have too much
to do all the time,
well, then make some changes, don't let
what everybody else wants run your life,
take your life back, I
think under God's direction
and leadership, we need to
take charge of our lives
and we need to start putting our time
into what we want to put it
into instead of just what
everybody else wants us to put it into
and I don't mean by that
that we don't do things
for people, we all should
be busy doing things
for other people, we all
should serve, we have jobs,
we have responsibilities,
but don't just let all
your circumstances rule you
and everybody else's decisions
about what they want you
to do for them rule you,
take your life back,
so I want to share with
you a little exercise
that I think you can do at any time,
I've been doing this and I'm
finding it very refreshing
and that is simply to
stop several times a day
and just say, Lord, I want
to just live this moment
that I'm in, you know, so often we don't,
we're breathing, but
we're not really living
the moment that we're in, we're
in such a frustrated uproar
over all the things that
are going on in our lives
that so much of our day just flies by
and at night we don't even
really know what we did
but we know it was pretty frustrating
and we didn't enjoy all
that much of the day
and I think it's a very good exercise
to stop several times a day and just say,
now Lord, I'm going to
enter into this moment
and really just live this
moment and to think about
and to tell God what
you're thankful for at that
particular moment in your life.
And there was a certain man, verse five,
who had suffered with a
deep seated and a lingering
disorder for 38 years, a
disorder for 38 years, and
it's this man right here.
And Jesus said a most
amazing thing to this man,
when Jesus noticed him
lying there helpless,
knowing that he'd already been a long time
in that condition, he
said to him, do you want
to become well, well, what
kind of a question is that?
Do you want to get well?
- Sure.
(audience laughs)
- And then Jesus goes a little deeper,
he says, are you really in
earnest about getting well?
And then the most amazing
thing, the invalid answered him
and said ...
- I don't have anybody
to put me in the pool.
- [Joyce] And?
- Every time I try,
somebody gets in front of me
and they get their healing and not me.
- So when Jesus said to him,
do you really want to get well,
he said, I have nobody
to put me into the pool.
(audience laughs)
He was waiting for
somebody to do it for him.
You say, well, Joyce,
give the guy a break,
he was crippled, well, I
want to tell you something,
in 38 years, I could have
done a lot of wiggling.
(audience claps)
(laughs) I mean, in 38
years, if you only wiggled
a little part of an inch every year,
I mean, he had 365 days to wiggle.
(audience laughs)
Just a little bit, but the
only thing he could say
to Jesus, was, there's
nobody to put me in the pool,
and when I try to get up,
somebody gets ahead of me.
Now Jesus didn't say, oh, you poor man,
I cannot believe that you
have been laying here 38 years
and nobody has put you into the pool,
that is really terrible.
- I know.
- It's really bad, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- [Joyce] Just really bad?
- I'm glad you're starting
to see things my way.
(audience laughs)
(Joyce laughs)
He's getting this, he's
actually got, I think,
tears in his eyes, now, you
know, Jesus being loving
and kind, I would think that
he would have just said,
that is the most horrible
thing I ever heard,
I am going to fix your problem tonight,
but here is what Jesus
said to him, verse eight,
Jesus said to him, get up, get up!
(audience cheers)
Get up!
And pick up your bed and walk, go home
with that mess you've
made in the last 38 years,
get out of here and
live your life, get up!